spider-man 3 that's right we have gotten
to that point in this series oh boy
this is really the first time you could
tell that Sony had gotten their hands
way too involved with this project but
hey at least they didn't do it again I
remember being at the 12:00 a.m. release
of this movie with my friends we were in
this packed theater everyone was so
excited everyone was still riding the I
there was spider-man 2 and when it ended
I walked out of there with my head hung
really low this was one of the most
disappointing movies I've ever seen in
my life now look this isn't Batman and
Robin bad it's just a massive letdown so
let's talk in depth about spider-man 3
spoilers of course the strange thing for
me about spider-man 3 is that the things
I dislike the most about it actually
aren't the story inconsistencies and the
script problems because those are
problems where you film your movie and
then you watch the final cut and you're
like oh my gosh all these things I did
wrong I wish I did that differently
those mistakes happen my biggest issues
with spider-man 3 revolve around what
I've come to call the WTF moments of
spider-man 3 these are things that don't
make sense that happened throughout this
movie things that if anyone had just tap
somebody on the shoulder and said hey
that's stupid don't do that
they groove avoided it like this part
for instance there's a change in the
silicon mass it's probably a bird it'll
fly away when we fire it up really a
bird penny why does she have a locket of
herself she gives her dad a locket and
it's a picture of her what kid carries a
locket of themself makes no sense then
there's this guy I call him the shovel
cop these two cops are chasing Flint
Marko an escaped convict they chase him
into this truck this pit of sand he
raises this shovel above his head like
he's about to decapitate this escaped
convict or at least impale him with the
shovel what when Peter gets his black
suit he's just like
this is something else he never once
questions it he just accepts it it's
really cool I guess
Peters hair color also changes
throughout the movie it goes from being
dyed black to back to brown again with
no explanation I guess the symbiote
changes his hair color and also gives
him beautiful full eyelashes and then
they actually do this cliche I mean the
entirety of the spider-man films up to
this point we're fairly serious Harry
can't just vaporize at a coffee shop and
of course this entire scene this is
without a doubt the low point of the
entire spider-man trilogy
Harry's Butler randomly showing up and
going hey
your father died by his own hand Harry I
cleaned his wounds it's so dumb why did
he wait so long to tell him this it's
such terrible storytelling well they
were filming this scene they should have
known it was a bad omen when the actor
couldn't get his line correct the blade
that pierced his body came from his
Gilder okay
it's lighter that's right bite it the
blade that pierced his body came from
his trailer those are my WTF moments
with spider-man three things that just
don't make any sense things that could
have been avoided if someone just said
hey that's really dumb don't do that
let's talk about the major issues with
this movie it's the script it just can't
balance how many characters and subplots
are being introduced into this film in
fact one of the many screenwriters had
originally wanted to turn this into two
parts because there's just so much going
on Peter Parker Harry Osborn and Mary
Jane are once again in the middle of a
love triangle drama Harry is the new
Goblin all of a sudden but then he loses
his memory and instantaneously becomes a
less compelling character there's drama
going on with MJ's play that she's in
she gets terrible reviews from critics
and she gets fired Sandman has a
daughter who's sick and he's trying to
figure out how to provide for her the
symbiote shows up on a meteorite and
turns spider-man into black suit
spider-man and if there wasn't already
enough characters Gwen Stacy gets thrown
into the mix for a second love triangle
and even still another character Eddie
Brock
thrown into this blender and he
eventually turns into venom for like
five seconds because the studio clearly
wanted venom in this movie and Raimi was
like fine plus Aunt May's involved with
this movie and they try to give another
subplot that Sandman is actually Uncle
Ben's killer this movie is a
scatterbrained mess one of the things
about this movie that surprised me so
much is the CGI the first two films were
not over reliant on it especially the
first film it was there but it wasn't
used as a crutch
spider-man 3 most definitely uses it in
that way there are so many fully
rendered digital human faces that take
me completely out of the movie it didn't
work for me in oh seven it definitely
doesn't work for me today and the green
screen early on in the scene with Harry
attacking Peter is unforgivably bad now
like I said this movie isn't steel
starring Shaquille O'Neal it's not that
bad it's not fan for stick there are
aspects of spider-man 3 that I enjoy so
let's talk a little bit about those the
birth of Sandman the sequence is
beautiful has a great score by
Christopher Young who replaced Danny
Elfman it's all visual storytelling with
no dialogue I like Peter in the church
tower ripping the symbiote off of him
Kirsten Dunst in the entire film she's
the only character that isn't an
oblivious idiot and her performance is
very good Bruce Campbell in the French
restaurant scene his third cameo in the
spider-man series he's excellent and
really funny I love this line see it
chump
I like black suit spider-man vs. Sandman
in the subway and I like the
bare-knuckle fight between Harry and
Peter oh look at little Goblin Junior
kry and my favorite part in the entire
film is Harry and Peter finally teaming
up together at the end it's really
inspirational it's awesome it's good to
see their friendship back and it was
sort of like your first little hint of
what the Avengers could maybe be like
seeing superheroes team-up so look when
I rewatched this movie I really thought
about it I took some notes and I came to
a realization I think I figured out how
to fix spider-man 3 I thought up a whole
new plot here it is completely remove
Sandman and venom that would get rid of
the black symbiote the stupid Topher
Grace stuff and the stupider dance stuff
make the main villain of this movie
Harry the entire series has been
to this anyway the first film is hairy
completely jealous at Peter because
Norman is showing Peter gratitude and
treating him like the son he never had
the second film Harry's even more pissed
at Peter for not letting him know who
spider-man is and of course at the Andy
realizes that Peter is spider-man
discovers all the Goblin Tech the whole
series has been building to this let
Harry be the villain of this entire film
and of course scrub the stupid memory
loss idea also don't include gwen stacy
there is no reason for another love
interest just have MJ be there
supporting Peter there doesn't have to
be any more relationship drama
we've already had two films of that quit
making Peter so oblivious at everything
he's constantly telling MJ just get back
on the horse it's gonna be fine he's had
to believe in yourself and blah blah
blah
it actually makes them a little
unlikable that he is so oblivious to
everything going on around him in the
finale rather than Harry and Peter
teaming up to fight some random villain
that suddenly appeared have them be in a
vicious battle with one another towards
the end of it Peter is absolutely
railing on Harry he beats Harry to
almost near death to a pulp and the only
reason he doesn't kill Harry is because
MJ stops him at the last second everyone
collapses they're staring at each other
Harry is nearly dead this dark rage is
boiling within Peter and Harry in that
moment has a realization of what he's
done and that he was on the wrong side
of things they have a very beautiful
heartfelt conversation and just when
Peter thinks it's going to be okay Harry
takes one of the bombs and blows it up
in his face killing himself it would be
a very sad ending it would be a tragic
ending but it would be a much better
ending at a much better film than what
we got and it would have been much more
focused and the rage that Peter showed
in that battle could hint at venom and
black soot being in spider-man 4 and how
that rage could actually affect him in a
bad way and it would have set up that
possibility considerably better than him
just going around going down out there
now get out now and that's how I think
they could have fixed spider-man 3 guys
I don't hate this movie it's not a
terrible movie there are some good
things in it nevertheless I'm going to
give spider-man 3 a c-minus
guys please stay tuned for my review of
the Amazing Spiderman very soon you guys
are the best thank you so much for
watching if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck my nice